hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast data integrity and the FDA
guidance
I am Kristen Perez and you love lab
routes and I'll be your moderator for
today's event we are delighted to bring
you this educational web seminar
presented by labret for more information
please visit labret comm this event is
sponsored by Beckman Coulter life
sciences scientists use Beckman Coulter
life science research instruments to
study complex biological problems
including causes of disease and
potential new therapies or drugs their
particle characterization business
serves biopharma production and QC
environments as well as research
functions within large biopharma
companies we have a few important
announcements before we begin this
webcast is designed to be interactive
and we encourage you to ask questions
during the event you can submit
questions by typing them in the green
Q&A box which can be found by clicking
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window we'll
try to answer as many questions as we
can at the end of the presentation you
can enlarge the slide window by clicking
on the screen icon in the lower right
hand corner of the slide window if you
have any technical problems viewing or
hearing this presentation please click
on the support button at the top right
of your presentation window or submit
your problem through the green Q&A
button lower left I would now like to
introduce today's speakers Tony Harrison
Tony held the convention of the ISO
working group revising ISO one four six
nine eight one and batch two for
microbial control in clean rooms and was
the UK subject matter expert into the
ISO working group who issued the 2015
revised versions of the ISO one four six
four four - one and - two documents for
cleanroom classification at the heart of
the aseptic manufacturing chapters of
at the European GMP and the USA CCMP
document Toni holds a bachelor's degree
in electrical and electronic engineering
and is employed by Beckman cultural life
sciences as a senior marketing manager
experience in water system toc
conductivity and ozone analysis and
cleanroom environmental monitoring as
well as particle characterization Tony
has spent the last 15 years in applied
metrology for the pharmaceutical and
healthcare manufacturing industries
prior to that he worked for companies
providing process control automation
solutions for manufacturing industries
for Tony's complete bio please see lab
reeks comm and Tony now we turn it over
to you
great thank you very much for the
introduction hello everyone my name is
Tony Harrison from Beckman Coulter thank
you very much for joining me today I'm
going to talk about the FDA's 21 CFR
part 11 rule particularly in the context
of cleanroom environmental monitoring
classifications for the pharmaceutical
manufacturing industry a recent report
as I read suggested that circa 79% of
the FDA's 483 warning letters issued in
2016 to the pharmaceutical industry
cited deficiencies and their data
integrity and despite guidance from the
FDA the cleanroom environmental
monitoring remains an intensely manual
process with many opportunities of human
error to create gaps and errors in the
data in their 21 CFR part 11 guidance
the FDA have given recommendations on
what good data integrity looks like when
this presentation explains their advice
in the context of current cleanroom
environmental monitoring practices and
shows how the FDA guidance can be
applied to improve data integrity
first of all let's look at some guidance
the FDA gives and look at the history
behind the 21 CFR Rule part 11 rule and
also some common misconceptions in 1997
in the face of pressure by the
pharmaceutical industry to move away
from paper records and to electronic
record-keeping the FDA issued their
original 21 CFR part 11 guidance
documents on best practice for using
electronic records at that time the
industry was somewhat dismayed that the
advantages of electronic record-keeping
appeared to be outweighed by the
apparently burdensome requirements
imposed by this guidance and there was a
lot of pushback against the FDA and
their advice the FDA realized that the
pharmaceutical industry were taking
their guidance as all encompassing and
recognizing the need for clarity
they issued further guidance back in
2003 this effectively limited the scope
of the 21 CFR part 11 ruling to those
records that are either directly covered
by the FDA regulations or those that are
submitted to the FDA under the Federal
Food and Drug Cosmetic Act of 1938 and
the Public Health Service Act of 1944
the FDA is 2003 document provided
detailed descriptions of those records
where 21 CFR part 11 should be strictly
applied and it dispelled some common
misconceptions that may surprise you the
first common misconception is around use
of PDF file type for electronic records
many people as I travel around the world
get concerned about the fact that PDF
document could be edited deliberately to
hide some sort of quality issue but that
is not the concern that the FDA is
trying to
address in their guidance in their 2003
guidance the FDA sought to make it clear
that there so that 21 CFR part 11 was
not written to try to prevent criminal
activity it was actually written to
avoid manufacturers accidentally losing
or not being able to read their
electronic records risk retrospectively
many interpret the rules enforcing
encrypting a cryptid file formats or
formats that cannot be deliberately
edited this is not the FDA's intention
just as with paper records the FDA
intention is that the record should be
kept safe and secure so they can be
retrieved when required at some point in
the future you can see the excerpt from
the FDA guides on screen here and you
can see they suggest PDF as one of the
file formats and just as with paper
records it's not the format of the
record that the FDA is concerned about
it's the way they are stored to prevent
accidental corruption of new information
contained in the record or loss of the
record itself for example electronic
records stored in some proprietary
formats in an archive that only works on
the computer say running Windows XP for
example there are likely to be
accessible in ten years time but it will
be almost impossible to find a computer
that can still run Windows XP so to
prevent such mistakes the FDA recommends
electronic file formats that are
designed to be readable on many
different platforms one of those is of
course PDF which of course can be read
on Windows platform Apple Android etc
etc electronic records stored in PDF
format are far more likely to be
readable in ten years time that being
said of course the archive where the PDF
files are kept should be controlled to
prevent accidental or deliberate changes
or deletion of the PDF files
the second in common misconception is
that all computers all computers and
devices use on a pharmaceutical
production facility need to comply with
the 21 CFR part 11 rule this is a
misconception in their 2003 guidance the
FDA go to great lengths to explain the
only computer that needs to comply with
the 21 CFR part 11 ruling is in fact the
one where the electronic records are
stored they even go on to point out that
if the final records archived and used
demonstrate batch quality to the FDA a
stored in paper format then the 21 CFR
part 11 rule does not apply to any
computer even to the computer used to
create the paper record in the first
place ie if the triangle record is kept
in paper format and not electronic
format and the 21 CFR part 11 rule does
not apply at all so let's see take a
look at what other guidance the FDA
gives on this topic in their 2003
guidance on the implementation of their
21 CFR part 11 data integrity rule the
FDA used the acronym
Alcoa where they define good data
integrity practices creating records
that are attributable to the technician
carrying out the testing are legible are
created contemporaneously are original
and accurate this slide shows that the
dictionary explanation of attributable
but in this case the attribute or means
the record should be should include an
electronic signature to link them to the
technician we did the test and they
should also include a label stating
where the sample was taken and of course
our time and date stamp
the L in our color is legible and the
record
course is required to be legible and
that kind of implies that handwritten
records not really acceptable the FDA
goes on to suggest electronic records
should be stored as I mentioned earlier
in a format that is open and can be read
on many computing platforms so that it
will be accessible and readable for
years to come the FDA not only
recommends PDF as I've mentioned but
also XML and sgml which can be read by
web browsers the C in our color is
talking about contemporaneously and
contemporaneously according to the
dictionary means to existing or
occurring at the same period of time and
what their what the FDA mean in this
instance is that contemporaneously
implies the electronic record should be
created immediately the sample is
measured implying that manual
transcription of paper records at a
later time
is not good practice and action
collating paper records and then
manually transcribing them into an
electronic format at a later time or
date is again not good practice the O in
our color suggests original the
dictionary says the earliest form of
something from which copies may be made
now in this context the there's
naturally a danger with every
transcription of test results from one
form to another even scanning multiple
paper records into electronic format
runs the risk of duplication or even
missed scans so the FDA recommends that
the electronic record should be the
original record created when the test
was completed
obviously manually transcribe records
are the riskiest attracting the biggest
opportunity for human error
finally the a in alcoa naturally the
record should be accurate of course it's
obvious and this implies that the
process of capturing those electronic
records should be robust i manual
calculations manual data entry where
opportunities for human error exist
should be avoided so that's the Alcoa
guidance from the FDA so let's take a
look at this particular rule and
guidance in the context of
pharmaceutical cleanroom environmental
monitoring of course the FDA mandates
the air quality conditions for
pharmaceutical production it should
maintain certain air quality in fact as
those in the audience will know the real
danger is not particulates in the air in
the cleanroom but it's in fact the
microbes on this human body human shared
around 30,000 skin cells per hour and
all of which of course are potentially
carrying microbes unfortunately we don't
have a technology available today which
can detect real-time these microbes so
that's why use air particle counters in
fact a human body sheds approximately
3.6 kilos of skin per year.if
increasingly the burden of carrying out
the environmental monitoring on a daily
basis is moving away from the quality
control microbiology team over to the
production staff and this is
predominantly for two reasons I've been
told a of course the microbiology staff
are unfortunately relatively expensive
to employ and be it of course reduce its
number of people inside the clean rooms
because the production staff are already
inside the clean rooms so it saves
sending extra people into the clean
rooms which could be a source of
potential product current contamination
however the downside of this is of
course the production team do not have
the same level of knowledge about
routine environmental monitoring and
microbiology and this I've been told by
many people across the world is creating
challenges in itself
as I said at the start of this talk
today that a recent report I read
suggests that circa 79% of the 483
warning letters issued by the FDA in
2016 to the pharmaceutical industry
cited deficiency in their data integrity
integrity so this is clearly a worldwide
problem in fact most places I travel to
around the world I see people talking
about this issue 21 so 20 years after
the original FDA 21 CFR part 11 guidance
was issued industry remains very very
focused on ensuring the integrity of the
final record however many processes
leading up to the creation of the
electronic record remain intensely
manual and paper-based leading to the
opportunity for human errors to create
error in the final record or even data
gaps so if we look at the typical
cleanroom monitoring process that's
where everybody focuses on the
electronic record storage but if we
think about it the actual process to get
to that electronic record particularly
in cleanroom environmental monitoring is
intensely manual using manual SOPs
manual programming all the air particle
counters typically the paper record from
these counters is scanned and then
typically manually transcribed so you've
got those five steps all the way before
it gets into the electronic records so
these are the areas where data errors
introduced data gaps occur so in
my travels around the world speaking to
different production facilities it's
quite common that there are teams are 10
or more technicians whose job it is
every month take thousands of routing
environmental monitoring samples at
every location may have to follow the
SOP and manually type the location name
into the air particle counter before
they start sampling the counters
themselves typically are manually
configured following the written SOPs at
the end of each day the paper printouts
from each sample location have to be
photocopied because of course the
printers on the particle counters are
thermal printers and the printouts fade
over time and then the results from
every location have to be mainly
transferred into electronic format one
by one as I mentioned the recent report
shows a data integrity is very much at
the forefront of the FDA's mind and this
is a they publish their 483 warning
letters on the internet and this is one
I haven't find which actually states
that their concerns here with during a
two-year period in a sterile grade a
manufacturing environment they found
that there are eight hundred and forty
six pieces of environmental monitoring
data were not collected or were missing
during that time period so it's very
much on the FDA's mind and the other
common theme I'm finding as well is that
the FDA is saying that retraining is not
the solution so saying that the reason
we've got a problem with our
environmental monitoring is because the
staff need retraining again generally
the FDA is is not really happy with that
solution they're saying look by
retraining all you're trying to do is
treat symptoms and you're not curing the
disease it's only worked for a short
period until human error starts to creep
in again and what they really suggesting
is the correct way forward is to make
the play
more robust if we can automate it to
eliminate those human error steps that
will make it more reliable and robust
but be it will reduce the training
burden in the industry as well so if we
take a look at the typical environmental
monitoring practices in the light of the
FDA Alcoa guidance there are menu manual
steps in the typical environmental
monitoring process and the paper record
does not contain an electronic signature
so it's not attributed to the technician
sample locations and Magni typed in for
each location inviting human error
mistyping preventing the samples being
easily attributable to the same example
location and usually as I mentioned the
record is illegible but it's certainly
not computed in the contemporaneous
manner so it is a trivial well not
really - not generally linked to the
person or the location unless it's
manually entered which of course are
obviously a opportunity for human error
is it illegible the final record
definitely yes is legible it's typed
into an electronic format but certainly
not created contemporaneously typically
most people collect the paper printouts
over the day when they're doing their
routine your biomedical monitoring and
then manually transcribe them at a later
time or date so it's not
contemporaneously recorded it's not the
original record either because the
original record from the air particle
counter is a thermal printer and it
fades with time so it's not the original
record generally it is accurate but
there's an opportunity for human error
to creep in through all these manual
steps and so generally is not 100%
accurate unfortunately there is a
solution
Beckman cultura provided a solution for
this a fully alcoa compliant solution
the Met one air particle counters from
Beckman Coulter
can have the sampling SOP and locations
pre-programmed to remove the manual
sample location entry and counter
configuration steps sorry excuse me
so instead of producing paper records
afternoon man you need to inscribe at a
later stage the counter instantly
generates an electronic record that is
attributable as it contains the user's
electronic signature the sample location
name and its time time and date stamped
the electronic record created is both
legible and contemporaneously created
being one of the recommended formats
from the FDA which as I mentioned
earlier is PDF it is the original record
and it's transmitted by wired or wires
Ethernet to the secure server where the
files are kept so this collapses the
workflow completely and removes all the
manual steps thus reducing the
opportunities for human error and making
the record accurate so as I said to
reach the recent report suggests 79
percent of the FDA 483 warning letters
in 2016
cited deficiencies in data integrity and
despite that guidance clean room
environment camana turing mains and
intensity manual process lots of
opportunities for human error to creep
in and create gaps and errors in the
data when I'm hearing this on the global
basis as I travel around the world the
FDA is giving recommendations the Alcoa
recommendation of what they think good
data integrity looks like and the
solution from Betancourt is available to
help comply with the Alcoa guidance so
thank you very much for listening to me
today I do appreciate you taking the
time out of your busy days and I am
ready now if there are any questions
then I'd be happy to answer them thank
you
much for that informative presentation
mr. Harrison before we get started on
the question-and-answer session I would
like to remind our audience how to
submit questions you can submit your
questions by typing them in the green
Q&A box which can be found found by
clicking on the Q&A button at the lower
left is the presentation window we'll
try to answer as many questions as we
can and our first question for you today
is that you mentioned that PDF is an
acceptable file type for electronic
records how can you be sure that the PDF
file has not been altered yes certainly
as I mentioned in fact the FDA is really
less concerned with people deliberately
falsifying records than they are really
with ensuring the electronic record will
still be legible in years to come that's
why they suggest the PDF file type but
to answer your question it is easy to
check if a PDF file has been altered if
you simply right click on the file the
PDF file unstriped properties you can
check that the date and time the file
was created and the date and time that
it was modified are the same if the file
has been modified at some point after it
was initially created than it would show
up here in the properties okay thank you
why is it important that the electronic
record is created contemporaneously ya
know that's a good question really and
if you think about the heart of the
problem we're trying to address here
it's really human error in the process
of manually handling and transcribing
paper records into electronic format so
to reduce the opportunity for human
error the FPS encourages of the
instrument taking the measurement
creates the electronic record as soon as
the measurement is completed I
contemporaneously and that just removes
all those opportunities for human error
that can occur in a very manual
cleanroom environmental monitoring
process that we see today ok thank you
our next question we have in the Beckman
culture met one solution how do you
ensure that the electronic record is
attributable now that's a good question
and of course the FDA is looking at the
electronic record there's a tribute will
not only to the person or the technician
that made the measurements but also to
the location and it must be time and
date stamped where the measurement was
made so the electronic record created by
the Beckman Coulter met one solution it
contains all of those attributes all
pieces of information automatically it
contains the electronic signature of the
user the location ID and its time and
date stamped okay wonderful looks like
we may have one more question sure if a
particle counter makes an electronic
record and receipt print out at the same
time do you need to keep the receipt so
I'm assuming that the person asking the
question when they say we see they're
talking about the paper printout from
the parcel counter so it took that's a
very good question and there is an issue
of course as I mentioned all particle
counters have thermal printers so the
receipt or the ticker tape or the piece
of paper that it generates from the
front of the particle counter in fact
will fade over time so trying to keep
the original piece of paper is very
difficult it's challenging in itself so
but the best most people tell me they
can do is to photocopy those original
receipts or ticker tapes from the air
particle counter and keep that record -
now that's a good backup to the
electronic record but once you start
duplicating the storage of records it
can get complicated particularly if at
some point in time you go back to the
records and you find that the electronic
record and the take a record don't match
of course that shouldn't happen but
potentially can do so
a lot of people asked us just to remove
the printer from the net one particle
counters so they just take the
electronic record no longer take the
paper record and rely on the electronic
PDF file is generated by the particle
counter wonderful all right well if
there are no more questions I would like
to once again thank mr. Harrison for his
presentation do you have any final
comments for our audience no I thank
everybody for attending today and
listening to my talk I believe is a an
opportunity to download a white paper on
the subject if you're interested I
believe you can do that through replying
to the poll question that was sent out a
short while again far from that thank
you very much indeed thank you very much
mr. Harrison today's webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing through
January of 2018 you will receive an
email from labrys alerting you when this
webcast will be available for replay we
invite you to pour that announcement to
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event we'll see you next
time and goodbye
thank you